[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
jetzt kurz vor der weihnachtszeit gibt
es einen richtig tollen kinofilm der
heißt last christmas und ich hatte das
vergnügen und die erde mit dem kinofilm
bereits zur premiere anzuschauen in
berlin und habe dort sogar die
hauptdarstellerin getroffen im hinter
clark habe mich natürlich sehr gefreut
und bevor ich jetzt hier weitermache
würde ich sagen schauen wir uns den
trailer an gleich gibt's noch ein
gewinnspiel und ich mag natürlich eine
torte zu finden weihnachten wirklich
krank ich bin fast gestoßen
ich sag's nicht weil die leute sonst
komisch aber ich glaube kein anruf
du kannst mich mal anrufen
ich mache mir sorgen um dich
und wie klappt es mit der diät sie ist
nur müll
trainieren sie liebe setzen da so gar
nicht alkohol trinken noch nicht ich
bin's ich muss heute nacht irgendwo
schlafen sich hey du das ist mein
weihnacht 11 ein nichtsnutz der alles
lieber macht als arbeiten klingt noch
nie man könnte ihn auch die
fürchterlichste weihnachts als
enttäuschung nehmen
es gibt das dann dazu sehen sie durch
ungewöhnlich so ein vogel in der stadt
verdammt ist dass man glück
du hast dein leben weggeworfen du
arbeitest in einem weihnachts shopper
aber das ist nur ein nebenjob ich bin
kein karriere mein eigentlicher plan ist
ich werde eine berühmte sängerin chris
messina fantastisch fantastisch
nein das war echt scheiße
[Musik]
du schon sagst du mich sind wir noch zu
helfen immer so zynisch schonungslos ist
in dunkle zeit und dann kommt lieber mit
mir gesagt hast du vor serienkiller
mäßig rüber kommst du nie mehr als
einmal
ich habe den spaziergang sehr genossen
ich auch das wird sich richtig gut auf
mein sexleben auswirken
seit du wieder da bist habe ich das
gefühl die ist alles egal
als ich krank wurde fühlte es sich an
als hätte ich was besonderes hallo ich
konnte richtig gut singen ich hatte so
viele träume aber jetzt habe ich nur
noch angst ist okay das ist normal
[Musik]
wieso ich war das immer sein solltest
haben solche sind dass wir leben ich mag
diesen mann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da
[Musik]
und was jetzt wie war es zu hause die
halle man hat mich in den schlaf
gesungen bis der einzige mensch den ich
kenne bei dem in den schlaf gesungen
klingt wie waterboarding
[Musik]
richtig cooler trailern aber ich kann
euch eins sagen der film ist kitschig
süß aber er ist nicht so wie im trailer
also da kommt schon noch also wird schon
noch mal richtig überrascht deswegen
will ich euch wirklich empfehlen den
film anzuschauen
ab dem 14 november in allen kinos
deutschlandweit ich habe mir schon
zweimal angeguckt einmal auf englisch
einmal auf deutsch und fans sagt die
mädels aus dem team und die jungs wir
schauen ihnen noch mal gemeinsam an
danach war doch so einer karaoke-party
also ich glaube das wird ziemlich cool
das heißt wenn ihr den film wirklich
sehen wollt schaut ihn euch an
ich habe auf instagram ein gewinnspiel
gestartet und habe gesagt schaut euch
mal den trailer an
bereits vor einigen wochen und habe
gesagt was für eine torte könnte ich
dann zum film backen und daraus habe ich
dann vier vorschläge ausgewählt und sie
mit nach berlin genommen und emilia
clark und paul gezeigt paul ist der
regisseur des films und die beiden die
haben dann die gewinner ausgewählt so
last week's startete competition
community
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich war beim interview ziemlich
aufgeregt arbeiten bahn so sympathisch
das interview gegen insgesamt zehn
minuten wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr das
nochmal im gesamten hochladen und diese
torte ist jetzt dabei rausgekommen die
konnten sie ja nicht so wirklich
entscheiden was sie möchten deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht mache ich ein
geschenkpaket beziehungsweise 2 hier
unten steckt die torte dieses geschenk
dieses kann man auch essen und hier
vorne
die süße kate aus dem film als
weihnachts 11 und ich glaube das ist
eine torte die könnte wirklich auch sehr
gut zu weihnachten zu bereiten und vor
allem ist sie gar nicht so aufwendig und
so schwierig wie sie aussieht also würde
ich sagen starten wir direkt mit dem
backen für die rohmasse verwende ich 240
gramm weiße schokolade 240 g weiche
butter 80 gramm butter zucker einen
teelöffel vanille extrakt und etwas
verpasste ich habe hier 10.10 eiweiß
eine prise salz 70 gramm zucker 220
gramm mehl und zwei esslöffel milch oder
himbeergeist stelle hier schon mal die
weiße schokolade aufs warme wasser bat
da kann sich schon mal schmelzen und
früher hier in der rührschüssel die
weiche butter mit dem puderzucker
[Musik]
und ich kann in der zwischenzeit hier
schon mal in einer separaten schüssel
das eiweiß mit der prise salz steif
schlagen und dann da noch langsam
demokratie reden
[Musik]
hier gebe ich jetzt noch die grüne star
passte dazu da müsst ihr wege stoffe
achten was ich verpasst und keine
flüssige farbe und den teig werde ich
jetzt grün färben wird gleich die
gleiche passiert noch mal zu bereiten
und rot färben und dann habe ich später
eine rot-grüne torte
[Musik]
die ruhe ich jetzt kurz ein und dann
gebe ich noch das mehl dazu die milch
und den eischnee
im schnee am besten nicht ganz steif
schlagen sondern eher so ein bisschen
ich sage es jetzt schloss sich ja ich
glaube dass ich jetzt ein wort das passt
perfekt zu dieser konsistenz schloss
sich dem dadurch wird der teig bzw die
früher masse umso besser was aus eurem
kopf wieder schloss und jetzt völlig die
masse direkt in freiberg ringe einen der
mich bereits auf 20 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und kann dann den teig im
ofen backen
ich könnte natürlich auch der masse in
einem backen backen aber dann verlängert
sich die backzeit und das wollen wir
nicht ich will jetzt schnell backen und
gerade bei 20 cm finde ich bietet sich
so auf jeden fall an weil es wirklich
auf ein backblech passt und vor allem
habt ihr dann zwei bilden die noch
gleichmäßiger backen weil eben nicht so
viel masse drin ist
[Musik]
die kuren böden sind gebacken und
abgekühlt jetzt gewinne ich mich
natürlich direkt schon mal um die
füllung ich habe mir gedacht wir füllen
die torte oder ich fülle die torte mit
einer buttercreme und zwar die
italienische dafür habe ich jetzt
bereits eiweiß mit zucker und salz
verrührt und bei 70 grad erhitzt für
zehn minuten und damit eher kalt gerührt
hier in der separaten schüssel habe ich
die butter mit dem puderzucker verrührt
und da findet ihr auch das grundrezept
bei mir auf dem kanal wichtig ist
wirklich dass die eier masse auch
erhitzt wird weil sie so zum einen
stabil wird und mögliche keime werden
abgetötet und jetzt früher ich beide
massen
also kommt jetzt alles in eine schüssel
ich denke hier kann man auch wirklich
wunderbaren marshmallows lauf nehmen das
gibt es ja im glas so als brotaufstrich
und dann spart man sich auf jeden fall
auch das erhitzen und das früher aber
ich habe immer alle zutaten da das heißt
ich mache das einfach immer so ganz
schnell verrührt es hier mit dem
schneebesen und momentan schmeckt die
buttercreme erstmal noch neutral
ich habe nämlich auch kein vanille
extrakt drin aber hier kommt jetzt
geschmack rein und zwar etwas orangen
passte da gehe ich jetzt etwas zwei
teelöffel dazu
[Musik]
alternativ könnt ihr natürlich auch
orangen schale mit rein reiben müsse
aber darauf achten dass sie zum verzehr
geeignet ist also sie dadurch nicht
geschützt sein
und hier habe ich einfach direkt die bio
orangenschale und ein perfektes aroma
die buttercreme lasse ich jetzt hier
kurz stehen und kümmere mich noch um die
marmelade
hier nehme ich jetzt einfach meine
selbstgemachte marillenmarmelade marille
vanille aprikose geht natürlich auch da
nehme ich jetzt so ungefähr 200 gramm
geht da noch was mit dazu und kann sich
hier noch ein bisschen erhitzen
das könnte echt immer direkt im
schälchen machen weil die für jede haut
geeignet sind und dann nehme ich jetzt
auch sternanis mit dazu was nämlich noch
nelken und noch eine zimtstange und dann
wird es auch schön weihnachtlich ist
kompliziert direkt mit rein deswegen
wird auch die marmelade erwärmt damit
sie wirklich die arbeiten noch toll
ankam
ich habe jetzt einfach diese kleine
teilchen das reicht schon die schöne
sterne die sich immer für die deko auf
ich nehme doch keiner nelke ich nehm
vanilla extrakt halt ich hab ja schon
marille vanille
dann brauche ich gerne was also haben
jetzt hier drin vanille marille
sternanis und auch eine zimtstange aber
dann nehme ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
eine halbe zimtstange damit nicht so
viel wert
[Musik]
jetzt geht's an den süßen
weihnachtsessen und da zeige ich euch
jetzt eine ganz einfache technik wie
ihre figuren modellieren könnt wir
werden jetzt einen sitzenden 11 machen
oder eine elf in gibt's das 11 und 11 in
wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich mache
weiblichen 11
dafür brauchte etwas von land und jetzt
macht ihr der modelliermasse die stellt
ihr entweder her wenn er von land und
blüten passte vermischt im verhältnis
eins zu eins oder wenn ihr verband mit
zellulose pulver vermischt alles
natürlich es war
ich habe jetzt hier meinen grünen und
damit einfach dieses schöne satte grün
bleibt werde ich jetzt hier zellulose
bull vorgegeben und dadurch hätte der
von dann nämlich etwas besser aus und
die figur bleibt dann eben auch schön
stehen oder sitzen
sie hat einfach aus
[Musik]
und bei der hautfarbe hier habe ich
weißen vorgenommen weiße blüten passte
habt es vermischt mit etwas rot und gelb
und habe diesen schönen hautton bekommen
und jetzt nehmt ihr 30 gramm hiervon für
den kopf schlägt sie was drunter da
jetzt einfach nicht austrocknet dann
müsste wirklich aufpassen weil es dann
durch das cellulose pulver wirklich
schnell aushärtet und 45 gramm grün für
den körper und den rest verpacke ich
auch immer gleich luftdicht und starte
jetzt hier mit dem körper ich-form
zuerst eine kugel und dann einem tiegel
und da könnt ihr gerne auch immer mal
ein bisschen becker sterkel nehmen geht
ein bisschen einfacher und damit das
kleid hier unten so ein bisschen flach
auf legt nämlich den kegel jetzt in die
hand und streicht mit dem daumen hier
einfach runter da kommen ja gleich noch
die beide drunter daher lege ich jetzt
hier so zwei platzhalter hin
diese zwei pinsel damit sich das kleid
an der stelle so ein bisschen welt das
kann jetzt schon mal zur seite und ich
kann den kopf formen
da ist auch wieder das ausgangsprodukt
eine kugel und immer schön darauf achten
dass sie faltenfrei ist
und jetzt drückt ihr hier mit euren
fingern so eine kleine mulde rein für
die augen und hier unten dann so ein
bisschen die nase nach oben stoßen dann
könnt ihr im kopf immer mal wieder so
ein bisschen zusammenrücken dass er
nicht so rund wird mit einem kleinen
modelle werkzeug die nase noch ein
bisschen anstupsen und dann nehme ich
einen kleinen ball tun
da kommen jetzt die 2000 durch herein
von unten
[Musik]
hier in mund
und am ende ein grüppchen
[Musik]
da wird der kopf nicht flach wird drücke
ich den gerne hier rein ist nämlich
einen etwas größeren ball und drückt
jetzt hier die vertiefung für die augen
ein
es gibt hier einfach ein bisschen wasser
rein mit einem pinsel und klebt die
augen ein
[Musik]
dieses winzige stückchen braun nehme ich
jetzt noch für die augen kaum
[Musik]
das ist wirklich millimeterarbeit aber
jedes detail und sich jetzt nämlich noch
ein bisschen pulver farbe in rosa denn
sie bekommt noch rosa wangen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich noch ein bisschen weiße
verpasste und werde jetzt hier mit dem
mit winzigen wohl die sagen mit dem
winzigen boot hole
die weißen lichtpunkte noch in die augen
setzen und dann ist das gesicht so weit
schon mal fertig
[Musik]
das lege ich mal kurz zur seite damit
auch schon mal schön an trocknen kann
es gibt wirklich torten künstler die
machen figuren also da kann ich echt nur
davon träumen
aber ich denke mir halt immer ich mache
sie einfach ihr wollt ihr auch nach
machen aber ich bewundere wirklich diese
cache kunst wo detailgenaue lebens
getreue figuren gemacht werden schon
richtig hier ein bisschen weiß und rolle
es dünn aus
und dann nehme ich jetzt hier diesen
blumen ausstecher das wird jetzt der
kragen als ich versuche schon das kleid
von kate nachzumachen und hier schneidet
ihr dann ein kleines dreieck raus also
von hier bis zur mitte einfach so ein
viertel weg das lässt sich jetzt hier
kurz liegen und auch antrocknen denn
jetzt wer noch die arme geformt ich
glaube da kann hier keine gramm angabe
machen denn es ist einfach so wenig dass
vielleicht eure wagens nicht schafft
deswegen mache ich eine zentimeter
angabe
ihr braucht ein ungefähr 2 cm großen
ball den halbiert ihr dann formt wieder
eine kugel und dann einen langen kegel
was ihr seht eine kugel ist hier beim
figuren modellen immer ganz wichtig
unter den titel hier unten schon so ein
bisschen flach drücken und mit einem
ball tool mit kleine vertiefung
reinmachen
aus diesem weiß schneide ich jetzt noch
dünne streifen zu
[Musik]
dann bestreite ich hier die ärmel unten
auch mit etwas wasser und legt dann bis
weiß wo direkt offen herum
[Musik]
ans ende kommen dann noch zwei kleine
kugeln aus dieser hautfarbe das sind
dann einfach die hände
also wir machen jetzt wirklich alles
ziemlich vereinfacht und die könnt ihr
dann auch mit etwas wasser ankleben
[Musik]
und zum stärkeren ankleben nehme ich
diesen s-bahn kleber und kann jetzt die
arme hier am körper befestigen
[Musik]
hier oben gebe ich jetzt noch den kragen
an
und dann kommt jetzt hier noch ein
zahnstocher rein damit ich später den
kopf eben auch schon aufsetzen kann
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich den körper und den kopf
erstmal antrocknen so etwa eine stunde
und kann dann wieder daran weiter
arbeiten und diese arbeit ihr könnt ihr
wirklich auch schon tage oder wochen im
voraus machen denn die figuren werden
nicht schlecht sie hätten einfach immer
mehr aus das heißt sie werden dann von
tag zu tag immer stabiler
jetzt setze ich die figur hier nach oben
denn auf der torte wird sie auch erhöht
sitzen und die beine hängen herunter
also nehme ich jetzt hier wieder etwas
weiße masse ich mache jetzt nicht wie im
film eine graue strumpfhose mit glitzer
sondern eine weiß rote so wie es
eigentlich für eltern sich gehört weiß
rotes hemd passt hier sehr gut und jetzt
einfach zu einem langen strang formen
die machen jetzt wirklich ganz
vereinfacht lange spaghetti beine hat zu
mir gesagt du hast spaghetti beine und
er hat immer gesagt wenn ich gerannt bin
haben sie sich wie in so einem
zeichentrickfilm in so einem cartoon
immer so und damit hingefallen
wieso ein knoten erst mal weg ich bin
immerhin gefallen beim rennen ist nicht
schlimm ich bin wieder aufgestanden
[Musik]
doch auch wegen auslaufender langen
beinchen aber ich denke ich kürze sie
auf eine schöne lange ungefährlich hier
[Musik]
so gefallen mir die beine jetzt ganz gut
hier oben habe ich etwas flach gedrückt
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen kleber dran
[Musik]
dann kann ich die figur drauf sitzt und
die roten streifen die mal ich dann
später drauf ihr könnt aber auch roten
von dort nehmen dünn ausrollen und nach
außen rum wickeln ja so sieht schon mal
songs
jetzt nehme ich noch mal ein bisschen
von meinem grün wohin hat das weg die
saison war unterwegs in zweiter oder wie
tatsache und jetzt 92 reichen wenn ihr
neben dir ein bisschen grün für die füße
das heißt für die schuhe und die pharmig
jetzt vorne auch ein bisschen spitz
damit eben auch schöne elfen schuhe
werden und dann am besten mit einem ball
rein drücken und an die füße ankleben
und da lege ich jetzt was drunter
damit die füße bzw die schuhe eben auch
dran kleben können
[Musik]
kleber lege ich jetzt hier auch noch hin
damit die spitze einfach schön nach oben
gebogen bleibt ohne zu lasse ich die
figur erst mal richtig durch trocknen um
sie dann fertig zu dekorieren
[Musik]
eine backstreet boys drehung ja und
extreme hier bin ich jetzt machen wir
den haaren weiter für die haare habe ich
hier ein sattes gelb und form jetzt
lauter kleine kugeln so etwa ein
zentimeter groß den rest trage ich schon
mal dick und jetzt kann ich den kopf
hier oben am zahnstocher ankleben
die kugelform ich dann wieder zu einem
tropfen einfach unterschiedlich groß
drückte flach und dann könnt ihr damit
eine modelle werkzeug oder einem
stumpfen messer so eine leichte struktur
rein bringen
ich habe jetzt ein stumpfes messer
[Musik]
und dann kommt das hier direkt an den
kopf aber ich werde zuerst einmal hinten
die längeren haare hin machen und vorne
dann so obendrüber die kürzeren
ich glaube dass untere haar mache ich
sogar erst mal so da ist nämlich
flächendeckender und oben ist im prinzip
komplett egal wie es aussieht denn es
kommt sowieso noch die elfen mit zu
drüber einfach wieder mit etwas kleber
dran kleben
[Musik]
ich find es schon ganz süß sieht vor
allem sehr 11 haft und lieb aus die
lasse ich jetzt auch so ich mache es
nicht mehr haare wenn ich jetzt keine
elfen mitmachen wird würde ich noch
bissl voluminöser haare machen zumal
kate ja auch richtig schöne haare hat
aber jetzt kommt hier noch die elfen
mütze also brauche ich wieder mein grün
und dafür vor mich jetzt einen kegel wie
immer und höhe denn so ein bisschen aus
das heißt mit einem ball tool so
wirklich eine mütze entstehen lassen
[Musik]
mache dir jetzt so eine falte rhein
gucken ob es passt auch das sieht doch
süß aus die elfen mütze bekommt ihr c
einen weißen saum sowie das kleid auch
[Musik]
jetzt wird sie fertig ist fällt uns auf
die mütze von kate war gar nicht so die
hängt runter also muss ich so noch mal
frisch machen eine kleinere eine runde
hängende
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die schuhe noch einen
bommel jeweils an die spitze
und natürlich die mit auch
[Musik]
mit roter lebensmittelfarbe mal sofort
strumpfhose an ihr könnt gerne wie im
film die strumpfhose jetzt selber machen
oder eben mit rot weißen streifen
ich mache jetzt rot weiß
[Musik]
ich glaube meine kate ist jetzt fertig
und darf jetzt einfach komplett noch
durch trocknen und mehr beim backen und
dekorieren zu schauen
ich mache jetzt hier meine reist riss
biomasse ich hab's dir wirklich schon
lange nicht gemacht aber da ich ja diese
geschenkbox auf die torte stellen möchte
gibt die rays crispy masse ihr könnt die
geschenkbox auch aus einem kuchen machen
also dafür einfach einen biscuit backen
füllen und aufeinander schichten ich
nehme jetzt reiß grimasse
dafür brauche ich marshmallows schoko
crisp ist nämlich dass zimt mit rein und
butter und das erste was ihr macht ist
marshmallows schmelzen entweder in einer
beschichteten pfanne bei niedriger hitze
oder in der mikrowelle
ich gehe es in die mikrowelle also nicht
ich aber die marshmallows weil es da
einfacher geht um schneller geht
hast du kannst jetzt aufgeregt sein das
ist ein erstes mal mit marshmallows und
preis christi und zieht gleich so cool
aus ich mach mal zweieinhalb minuten
beim maximum kommt man auf so eine rein
filmen kannst
[Musik]
schön geschmolzen und wirklich
vorsichtig sein die sind jetzt so heiß
also nicht rein fassen
um euch zu zeigen wie heiß die
marshmallows jetzt sind kommt der cd
butter rhein und die schmilzt drin
deswegen wirklich sehr vorsichtig sein
hier kurz einrühren
und jetzt wird spaßig jetzt hätte ich
meine arbeitsplatte ein bisschen mit
bakterien straight gewährt die schoko
christie's drauf hast du darfst gleich
müsli essen mit milch ich hier mache ich
noch drauf hände einfetten und die
marshmallow masse direkt darauf geben
und dann alles verbinden und ich mache
das zum einen weiß gut schmeckt und so
anderen weil es echt spaß macht also
marcel wird mich jetzt auch dafür lieben
denn erlebt der reis christi masse ich
mache ich immer die doppelte menge das
er noch was übrig hat jetzt müssen wir
ein video machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt braucht ihr gar keine spezielle
form dafür
hier klopft das jetzt einfach hier um
das ganze ein bisschen zu verdichten und
eure nachbarn zu ärgern
auf die arbeitsplatte schon so ein
bisschen quadratisch später schneide ich
einfach die kanten weg beziehungsweise
die ränder weg um eben kanten entstehen
zu lassen und habe dann einen schönen
würfel
das ist jetzt so erstmal aus herten und
nach weiter mit der torte
ich war etwas in gedanken und ich habe
die tortenböden einfach schon
durchgeschnitten ist okay also jeden
boden einfach zweimal schneiden das
wirklich richtig tolle schöne dünne
böden entstehen und ich hatte zwei mal
geschnitten um es einmal zu halbieren
und obendrauf diesen dunkleren deckel
weg zu nehmen
das heißt ich habe hier ein bisschen
reste weil obendrauf kann sein dass so
ein bisschen brauchen wird aber innen
ist die farbe einfach richtig schön grün
und daraus mache ich später einfach
papst denn ich liebe cake pops sich hier
meine torten dreh flasche ich habe gates
immer voll gelogen machen warum macht
man cake pops macht doch einfach googeln
oder stil egal ich wollte sagen ich
liebe sie aber ich liebe dich jetzt
wisst ihr die wahrheit und dann nehme
ich jetzt einen garching bord und werde
jetzt die tortenböden ein bisschen
kleiner ausstechen damit ich später das
ganz schön bord zum glatt streichen
benutzen kann
ihr seht dann was ich meine also die
tortenböden jetzt nehmen und bei bedarf
so ein bisschen ausstechen
[Musik]
ich setze hier den ersten boden auf
bestreichen mit der marmelade jetzt
schön weihnachtlich riecht und schmeckt
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt die luftiges zitronen
nein die luftige orangen buttercreme
drauf dünne schicht schön verteilt und
jetzt einfach die böden rot und grün
abwechselnd übereinander schichten und
wenn es für euch einfacher geht könnt
ihr hier gerne einen tortenring außenrum
setzen oder den tortenring erst außen
hin setzen wenn die torte praktisch
gestapelt ist
[Musik]
streicht die böden jetzt schon mal damit
die marmelade ein bisschen einzigen kann
sondern es nämlich das verstreichen der
creme etwas einfach
[Musik]
der letzte boden ich habe jetzt übrigens
immer die marmeladenseite umgedreht dann
ist es beim verstreichen wirklich
einfacher eine schöne hohe torte wird
jetzt hier noch das garching bord drauf
und ich konnte mir dann auch immer ob
sie schön gerade ist
[Musik]
perfekt hier am rand sehe ich noch die
creme kurz ab und normalerweise stelle
ich auch gerne ein tortenring außen rum
aber ich finde die torte sieht so schon
super aus das heißt die kommt jetzt so
erstmal in den kühlschrank damit sie
richtig schön fest wird und eben
auskühlt damit ich sie da noch schön
bestreichen dann auch das glück sich
einfach drauf die waage und ist gleich
jetzt ist die torte gut durch gekühlt
und ich werde jetzt hier mit der
buttercreme noch bestreichen
ich werde aber gleich noch eine helle
ghanas nehmen und zwar deswegen weil die
garage noch schneller fest wird als
buttercreme das heißt ich brauche ziehe
einfach mal kurz die buttercreme auf die
wird auch reichen zum kompletten
glattstreichen aber damit sie auch
wirklich richtig schön fest wird und ich
sehe dann relativ schnell und gut auch
mit von dann überziehen kann nehme ich
gerne aus und schon nochmal geschichte
und ich mag auch meister ghana schon
trocken aber später noch lieber aber ich
bin ich finde es sind so richtig
amerikanische weihnachts farben grün und
gelb rot weil ich das wenn man der
grünen roth schwäche hat welche farbe
hat die täterin grau ok es wird mich
jetzt aber tatsächlich interessieren wie
man das sieht wenn man eine rot grün
schwäche hat das heißt da gibt es dann
wahrscheinlich gar keinen unterschied
zwischen den tortenböden interessant
und deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier eine
kleine karte passt auch nicht dazwischen
okay dann schrecklich sie an und
streicht hier einfach die buttercreme in
die lücke stellt die torte kalt und dann
wird sie komplett mit der garage einmal
glatt gestrichen das ist auch richtig
durch
[Musik]
und in den garagen bord hat mir jetzt
wirklichen vorteil man kann die ganz
einfach großzügig auf tragen natürlich
auch die buttercreme hier so dazwischen
und dann mit einer großen teig karte den
überschuss ab 10
und dann sehe ich direkt auf einen blick
wo es noch fehlt kann die lücken
auffüllen und dann sind die seiten
wirklich in einem arbeitsgang richtig
schön glatt und 22
[Musik]
wenn der rand ganz schön platt ist kann
ich oben das caching bord abnehmen und
jetzt auf die oberfläche glätten
[Musik]
mainz christa block der ist es echt shop
fest ich habe knapp gegner war ja jetzt
schneide ich hier den boden weg brot und
kuchen und reis christina
[Musik]
der reis crispy würfel wird dann mit
einer dunklen garage als seinerzeit
peter karrasch gestrichen
da findet ihr auch das grundrezept auf
einem kanal ich fange da zuerst an den
seiten an
und sobald die glas sind kommt die
oberfläche und bei bedarf könnte den
würfel immer wieder kühl stellen sodass
am ende einfach schön glatt gestrichen
ist der würfel ist einigermaßen glatt
ich werde ihnen gleich noch ein bisschen
nach dem kühlen ausbessern
die torte ist auch glatt das heißt für
mich ich mache für heute feierabend
stellt alles in den kühlschrank und
morgen ist dann die von der decke dran
ich nehme jetzt zuerst mal hier ein
kickboard darauf werde ich die torte
nämlich servieren und dazu trägt sie
jetzt erst mal um das heißt ich nehme
dir jetzt hier runter und wenn sie so
eine nach dem kühlschrank war dann kann
man sie echt auch ganz gut am rand hier
anfassen weil sie wirklich schön fest
ist jetzt das caching bord lösen ihr
könnt im prinzip des cushing bord auch
drunter lassen
aber ich mache jetzt weg denn das war
unnötig ich habe dann mit platz runter
da ein bisschen gras drauf damit die
torte eben auch auf dem untergrund
haftet und steht platter drauflegen
ich hoffe ich habe es jetzt richtig
platziert
jetzt stelle ich die hier kurz zur seite
und diese torte werde ich jetzt mit
rotem von dort über 10
den kenne ich jetzt kurzweil
[Musik]
wenn jetzt auf etwas becker stärker
ausrollen
den verband habe ich jetzt richtig schön
dünn ausgerollt
jetzt kommt die torte und damit er von
dort drang haftet werde ich sie jetzt
einmal mit wachs trend spray einsprühen
jetzt überlegen und schön glatt machen
also erstmal die oberfläche und stände
hier unsere seite übrigens wenn ihr euch
fragt was das für eine kette ist die hat
meine tochter die samira für mich
gemacht und deswegen trage ich liebe es
auch voller stolz schön
und wenn dann alle falten erst mal
wechselt wird der überschuss
weggeschnitten
den könnt ihr natürlich aufheben und für
die nächste torte weiterverwenden und
dann die torte noch mal schön gelten
dann darf die torte wieder in den
kühlschrank und ich kann mich um das
kleine geschenkpaket kümmern
jetzt ist das geschenkpaket an der reihe
dies ist denke ich jetzt gold ein also
goldenes geschenkpapier unternehme ich
jetzt goldenen von dort das sieht so aus
wenn man ihn auspackt also bitte nicht
wundern denn so goldin von dort er
glitzert und glänzt gibt so gar nicht
das heißt man braucht ein zwei schritte
entweder nimmt man dann in gold spray
oder eben gold bruder und ich finde die
variante echt mitunter am besten
daher soll ich das jetzt erst mal dünn
aus und das gold päckchen dass es damit
dabei also habt ein prinzip 21 ihr habt
einen ockerfarbenen von dort und ihr
habt noch wollen von dort könnte beides
machen
und jetzt wird es hier zu einem langen
strecke ausgerollt jetzt habe ich gerade
meine 3 mm abstand bringe da drauf so
kann ich nämlich rollen so viel ich will
aber dünner als drei millimeter geht's
nicht dann habe ich es schön gleichmäßig
schneide ich das tier gerade weg
das netz noch hier die höhe der torte
aus auf allen seiten 9 und kann jetzt
hier das band dementsprechend zu
schneiden
[Musik]
die torte spricht jetzt mit fakten spray
ein dass auch hier davon doch wieder gut
dran pachtet legt das band außen rum und
kannst dann schön glätten
und jetzt einfach an der ecke schön
gerade wegschneiden
nun schlägt das jetzt einfach um und
kann schön die kommen ja auch glätten
sind schwierig gerade bei so kleinen
tropfen weil die so leicht sind und man
hat einfach kein widerstand aber einfach
so ein bisschen dagegen drücken
so sieht die geschenkbox jetzt aus und
ihr könnt es jetzt entweder trocken
pudern dann habt ihr so einen leichten
schimmer oder ihr feuchte die torte
jetzt ein bisschen an mit back translate
zum beispiel und dann wird das gold
richtig schön decken verteilt noch ein
bisschen
und dann wird es mit einem trockenen
pinsel drauf gefordert
[Musik]
wenn euch ein kleines missgeschick
passiert so wie bei mir her da ist
einfach die farbe ein bisschen
abgeblättert weil ich zu oft drüber
gegangen bin
dann nehmt einfach den pinsel da is back
transport drauf befeuchtet die stelle
noch mal an
und dann gehen wir dann noch mal mit dem
putter drüber
jetzt geht's an die deko der roten torte
dafür habe ich jetzt bereits weißen von
dort dünn ausgerollt und den schneide
ich jetzt erstmal hier geradezu da mache
ich jetzt nämlich eine bordüre okay ich
jetzt erst nicht zu schneiden müssen ich
schneide nämlich gleich noch mal zu aber
gut
dann arbeite ich jetzt umso vorsichtiger
könne nämlich zuerst die bordüre
eindrücken und dann zu schneiden ist ein
bisschen einfacher
[Musik]
jetzt hier schön gerade hinlegen und
dann nämlich gerade wegschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich so ein kleines
holzstäbchen und rolle ist hier auch
und jetzt trägt die torte einmal denn
ich fange mit der oberen bordüre an
[Musik]
streiche ich hier den rand ganz
vorsichtig und wirklich nur wenig mit
kleber und kannst hier anlegen und
abrollen
doch süß aus mensch und genauso schöne
bordüre kommt nach unten dran
[Musik]
und wenn ihr den rand so ein bisschen ab
streift dann sind die schneeflocken
richtig schön und fransen nicht aus
jetzt habe ich schneeflöckchen rentiere
und tannenbäume ausgestochen und die
klebe ich jetzt hier noch dran mit etwas
es waren kleber
[Musik]
und ich glaube ich mache das jetzt eben
wechsel tannenbäumchen erwähnt hier
ich war so ein bisschen hoch springen
wie vor da
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich eine lok hülle und steh
ich hier oben
heute schreien so kann ich noch mal ein
kleines detail muss damit reinbringen
[Musik]
ich nehme hier nochmal weiße
lebensmittel passte und wer jetzt hier
diese punkte machen am besten neben
dieser wegs und kleinen ball tool ich
glaube die nächsten punkte der sätze ich
hier rein und so könnt ihr wirklich noch
mal mit ein paar details die torte so
ein bisschen auffrischen und aufhübschen
und ich finde gerade details machen so
eine torte echt aus
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt rote modelliermasse
und schneidet dünne streifen so
[Musik]
dann lege ich jetzt hier ein holzstab
hin
ihr könnt aber auch ein ausdruck stab
zum beispiel nehmen und gerade so dass
drüber passt und an der stelle zu
verkleben
[Musik]
und diese längeren roten bändern die
werde ich jetzt direkt an das
geschenkpaket kleben
[Musik]
hätte ich noch eine andere bordüre und
die lege ich jetzt einfach hier oben
drauf und krebse hier fest so habe ich
auch oben einen schönen abschluss
[Musik]
ich mal ob die schleifen getrocknet sind
sie sind sie sind getrocknet und die
klebe ich jetzt hier drauf aber erst mal
drauf legen ob es mir überhaupt gefällt
und dann trifft leben
[Musik]
und manche schneide ich hier vorn ist so
zu
[Musik]
und hier oben rein da wo es eben nicht
ganz so hübsch aussieht kommt die solvay
nachts pflanze vielleicht wisst ihr wie
die heißt josch weihnachts ev hat einen
vorschlag
ja ich hab dich hier ebenso kleine
schälchen gelegt damit sie auch die
formschönen behält die gebe ich jetzt da
noch rein drei rote kugeln und fertig
[Musik]
zum anfang könnt ihr hier gerne noch
etwas darunter lägen damit einfach noch
gut trocknen kann und wirklich auch beim
trocknen schön diese dreidimensionale
form behält
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte zusammensetzen
das geschenk kommt jetzt hier praktisch
drauf und damit das geschenk durch das
eigengewicht die untere torte nicht
zusammendrückt kommt da jetzt ein übel
rein also einfach ein holz und damit ich
hier ein maß habe nehme ich jetzt einen
zahnstocher bzw schachspiels turn großer
zahnstocher einen lebensmittel stift und
dann hier kurz anzeichnen perfekt und
jetzt kann ich damit kurz in die
werkstatt gehen und den holz statt zu
schneiden
[Musik]
ich muss
wirklich leid die torte abend zu
schneiden die gefällt mir richtig gut ja
aber wir schneiden sie es an
ich habe noch zwei weihnacht zu helfen
hier kommt kaum einer links einer rechts
ach mensch macht sein gesicht
ich bin nicht eure roman heinrich keinen
crashs eine romantische stimmung ich bin
der grinch wie gefällt euch die torte
wir haben jetzt die essen wir fahren
jetzt aber die torte anschneiden
also ich habe zwei gewinner die
praktisch die torte vorgeschlagen haben
aber da ich mir gedacht weil so viele
mitgemacht haben wisst ihr was wir
verlosen noch was wir verlosen noch mal
einen v2 back rahmen und einen fußweg
back ring und dazu bekommt ihr noch den
last christmas kalender hat den
adventskalender und die elfe nur eine
elf müsse ja also dazu jedes paket ja
was müssen zuschauer zu machen und dafür
weiß nicht ob ich mir überlegt einfach
schreiben was sie mit dem song last
christmas verbinden zum beispiel okay
was wir sonst ja den hockenheimring
wir werden jetzt außer weil es gerade
rtl frage ostern
ich nehme jetzt nicht nehmen jetzt das
runter und ich sage dir wo die dümmste
antwort gibt's nicht gewonnen ich hoffe
du siehst du geschenk anschneiden also
das semi wirklich beeindruckend denn das
ist habe ich angst wenn ihr mir zum
riesen messen nutzen
hast du doch nicht morath
ich bin echt gespannt wie ihr euch jetzt
ihnen gefällt was dann irgendwas sagen
ich mag solche filme zu weihnachten ich
auch weil einfach mit kohle
einfach mal abschalten von allen anderen
ja so ein bisschen nass ist oder so
genau und da ist echt schön
die message in dem film d es so schön
ich meine ich jetzt nicht spoilern oder
so aber ihr müsst euch den film
weggucken und wir gehen als team
gemeinsam ins kino
ganz ehrlich jetzt kommt das moor athlet
allein 88 ganze kino kuchen risikolos
ist es nicht weihnachtlich das ist wohl
so richtig weihnachtlich ja sehr mag ich
habe eigentlich gedacht und haben
gedacht kommt orangen buttercreme schön
die probleme und sie noch fotografieren
will dürfte hier einfach gemeinsam ganz
romantisch probieren es so machen wie
weiße hochzeit dass er dass keines der
jetzt gegenseitig die augen verbinden
und dann blind über kreuz über kreuz
das auch sax nicht nach welches
süßigkeit schmeckt ist mit kurzfristig
besteht in den mund stimmt jetzt
geradezu über sachen gebacken habe nicht
probiert aber schmecken milchschnitte
schon mal kilo milch schnitte auf dem
teller
aber ich meine von seiner torte ich mein
ganzes stück ist ja kein mensch man
teilt sich das dann ganz romantisch und
falls ihr die torte nach machen wollte
würde ich mich wirklich sehr freuen
vielleicht ist es wirklich eine anregung
für ihre diesjährige weihnachtsdorf mir
gesagt geht ins kino schaut euch den
schönen film an
ich gucke ich mir ein drittes mal an
genau frohe weihnachten vorbei und jetzt
schon wieder ich weiß ist es noch früh
aber der film kommt halt jetzt november
in alle deutschen kinos und er heißt
könnte die stimme bisschen schöner
machen wenn du das wirklich so in die
länge ziehen
chefvolkswirt auf instagram der muba
kann man machen sondern ein
steuerberater der morath unterstrich der
muba zw
[Musik]